[Music]
all right ravi balani is here he was an
associate dfj
he did the justin tv which became twitch
investment but
as you've said you didn't you weren't on
the partner track you weren't able
and you didn't see a path to become a
partner at dfj
and so you wound up starting your own
accelerator
which has become successful and so this
leads me to wonder
why didn't they want you to be a partner
there were there just too many partners
or they didn't like you
or you were too you you don't work well
with other people you seem like such a
nice person
why didn't they make you a partner after
hitting a unicorn investment
uh thank you for the question jason
that's very flattering of you of of to
to ask um i should say first of all dfj
was the original anchor lp
and alchemist so they wrote the first
check and um that vote of confidence was
huge and i don't even know if alchemist
would have existed if dfj didn't become
the anchor lp
um but let me answer your question so
the reality was was that justin tv which
became twitch did not succeed it didn't
take
nobody knew that it was going to be big
until after i was tran after i left dfj
and so again these i think this is the
phenomenal thing about being in venture
is that you don't really know if you're
good or not for
seven to ten years right and um and so
um
um at the time i was four years into my
associate position and it wasn't clear
what was gonna happen with um uh justin
tv and with twitch and i should say
uh draper associates funded um uh
justin tv which was actually a fund that
tim draper
who's part of the dfj partnership has as
a special
vehicle so it was a little bit different
also on that regard so
that's the first thing is that twitch
was not a unicorn at the time that they
had to make a decision about
my status and the second thing is i
don't know if i would have
i think as you know jason is the thing
about venture capital firms is that it's
not really like an industry like that's
sort of a false analogy to think that
i think vc is like any other industry
like consulting or banking and you're
being promoted to partner
it's much more like little mafiosas like
each each each fund is its own family
and they have their own culture and they
have their own ways of making decisions
and really
when you think about these big names
like dfj or
you know mayfield or or usvp
um it's really like five people like at
the end of the day it comes to
like a small set of people that are
making some core decisions
and i think from their judgment
they didn't i mean i i i think that
if i think there was a feeling if i'm
that you know robbie was a nice guy that
i'm a nice guy but i don't have sort of
the sharp elbows to become a venture
capitalist wow
that's interesting i'm not i'm not
saying that they actually said that
explicitly but i think if i was trying
to be honest
on making that assessment that there i
think there was an assessment that i
was not um i was i was a good team
member but
i wasn't meant to become not cutthroat
enough to be a venture capitalist in
silicon valley they never said that they
never said that i just think that
there's your interpretation yeah but
there i think there's an assess and i
don't even know if they would
and i and that's probably overly um
specific and not necessarily but i think
there was an assessment that i wasn't
the right fit for the for the partner
path got it um
and i and i would say though that in
general the
the but the biggest blessing for me was
actually not
getting promoted to partner at dfj and
was um
having them have have the that was
having them fund
alchemist because yeah um that was my
alchemy that was my
path of actually the beautiful thing
about you know entrepreneurship is that
i think with alchemist we talk about how
like
you you would think about it as the out
the entrepreneurs the alchemist he's or
she
is creating all of this change by
transforming industries
but the reality is that the path of
entrepreneurship actually
can alkalize or can change the
entrepreneur
the very practice of going through and i
do think that that's what happened to me
was that i actually have developed
a lot from going down this alchemist
path
where i wouldn't have if i um stayed in
venture capital
so you uh start this alchemy and you say
i'm going to do
b to b i'm assuming this was because
y combinator was let's face it pretty
much a b to
c approach primarily at the time a
decade ago
or seven years ago i'm not sure exactly
when did you start alchemist
we started in 2012 2012 yeah so back at
that time
y combinator was you know probably
considered mostly b to c yeah so that's
why you went b to b or was just
something about b to b that you just
preferred
again this so no this was something that
we co-created so everything that we've
done that's been beautiful has been
co-created it's been with
with um in real time and agilely
developed
so what happened was we started and what
you're saying is essentially true but we
started
at the harvard club of san francisco and
this is when i was at dfj i was doing
these speaker series events so
i always loved teaching entrepreneurs
and in fact right now i also teach at
stanford and so i'm a lecturer in the
msn department we put up
all of our lectures at
ecorner.stanford.edu
but i also when i was at dfj i was
running these speaker series at the
harvard club
and we had we did this six-week program
where we just structured a bunch of the
key lessons into a six-week program we
didn't think about it as an accelerator
but we had all these amazing vps from
salesforce and oracle and all these um
big enterprise companies coming and we
were like why are you coming to this
harvard club speaker series and they
said because you know we don't need to
raise five million dollars you know
everything that was happening in the
consumer side
was happening in the enterprise side you
could do 500k could do what 5 million
did
10 years prior um but we want all the
education and guidance that we would
have gotten from a vc fund and y
combinator and 500 startups
are all much more geared towards really
you know building consumer companies
they were designed around
coming up with a chart that went up into
the right and then injecting fomo
and having everybody read into the tea
leaves and then write a check that i
mean that's an oversimplification but
there's a that's kind of sounds like a
bit of the playbook i mean
the the cynical view of accelerators
during that time
was they were taking the 100k and
spending it over 12 weeks
a little bit at a time and increasing
over each of the 12 weeks to build the
chart
and then if you were a savvy investor i
would say oh this is great look at that
chart okay yeah where did can you give
me
the source of each of these customers
show me where they came from and they're
like yeah this came from facebook i'm
like oh that's great
can you break it down on a percentage
basis for what's paid and what's not and
you'll be like oh
90 of this is just you paying to get
people to come to the website
i get it now that not that paid is not
real but you know you probably would
want to wait six months to see if that
cohort data if they actually stuck
around and it wasn't just gasoline on a
on a log being charred but not an actual
real fire of consumer passion